(crowd murmuring)
Ugh, this Nebula Strike
panel line's taking forever.
Uh, yeah.
It's taking longer than
when Corporal Snerdax
took his Galaxy Cruisers
to the Glorp System
to capture the Sporence traders
who had kidnapped Prolona
the Star Inquisitor, because
she had ruled against them
in the High Galactic
Court of Lumander Five,
because she had received a Blorff payoff
from the Delta Faction who
were trying to use the courts
to legitimize their hostile takeover
of the Encordium mines on
Dierkson's moon, Ontank.
I think you mean this
line is taking longer than
when Corporal Snerdax
took his Galaxy Cruisers
to the Klammen System to
capture the Sporence traders
who had kidnapped Prolona
the Star Inquisitor,
because she had ruled against them
in the High Galactic
Court of Lumander Five,
because she had received a Blorff payoff
from the Delta Faction who
were trying to use the courts
to legitimize their hostile takeover
of the Encordium mines on
Dierkson's moon, Ontank.
So, that's what you meant.
The Klammon system is actually very close
to Corporal Snerdax's home planet Junda,
which means that, using
the Galaxy Cruisers
Ion Tripler Engines, that, the
Yepping engineers developed
on Junda's moon, Carom,
from the Torium deposits,
it would actually take Corporal Snerdax
three milliseconds to synthwarp there,
which is in no way representative
of this very slow line.
What you meant to say, sir,
is that the Klammon system
is actually very close
to Corporal Snerdax's
home planet Junda, which means that,
using the Ion Tripler Engines,
that the Yepping engineers
on the Junda's moon, Carom, developed
from the Ladium deposits,
it would only take
Corporal Snerdax three
milliseconds to synthwarp,
which is in no way representative
of this very slow line.
I'll kick your ass worse than when
Lumander Five Venture
Brigade flew to Dierkson
to beat the Outer Brigands.
You mean you'll kick
my ass worse than when
Lumander Five Venture
Brigade flew to Ontank
to beat the Outer Brigands.
Hey, hey hey, stop, whoa
whoa whoa take it easy!
We all love the Nebula Strike movies.
Here, have a Snickers.
I still think you're way out of line,
confusing the Glorb system
and the Klammon system,
but hey, at least it's
cool that Corporal Snerdax
slaughtered those thousands
of Sporence traders.
Totally agree that Snerdax's
indiscriminate slaughter
was very cool.
Yeah, he really did wipe
out that entire planet,
and every living soul on it, didn't he?
He sure did.